[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now foundation all the space aficionados
are sort of marveling at the steampunk
technology just looking at here I'm
holding up the book because the book is
in the lobby in it's worth getting this
is such a classic long now subject and
sort of twice over because you're
already getting a message 40,000 years a
hundred thousand years it's a long time
to get to one of these distant stars or
even the close stars so you already have
to think long term to whatever technique
you develop and list really seriously
faster than light travel so then you
kind of work back from that horizon to
the horizon of what will it take to
develop interstellar travel and what I
love about the starship century the
hundred year starship and these several
different projects that are converging
and diverging is that they realize it'll
take a hundred years to solve the
problem it's very much like climate
change and what a fortunate century we
live in to have such interesting
problems to solve climate change and
figure out how the hell to get to the
stars a perfect person to talk about it
from long now standpoint is one of our
founding directors and one of the
leading futurists in the world Peter
Schwartz
[Applause]
thanks Stuart it really is a treat for
me to be here with all of you I know
many of you a lot of my friends are in
the audience and we've shared a lot of
ideas together over the years with long
now foundation so it's real pleasure for
me to be a part of this this evening and
for me this is also very personal I I'm
gonna I'm actually a rocket scientist
that's my degree it's the only virtue of
my degree I get to say that that I'm
actually rocket scientist well I say
that because you know I graduated from
college in 1968 just as the space
program had kind of peaked and was on
its way down after Apollo I worked on
Apollo but there wasn't too much future
after that I actually did want to be an
astronaut I grew up with science fiction
as a kid you know I destination moon
Forbidden Planet Flash Gordon these were
the things that that set me in motion
and I have been a reader of science
fiction all these years and still enjoy
it enormous Lee but what now has
happened is that it becomes actually
possible to think about some things that
were only possible in our imagination a
few years ago the the the the biggest
thing that has happened that really has
begun to change our thinking is that we
realize that our planet is not alone in
the universe until a few years ago we
really didn't know if our solar system
was really quite unique that you know
there might be just one solar system and
a bunch of stars with nothing around it
well what we now know as a result of
ground-based telescopes and some
space-based telescopes like Kepler is
that in fact planets are very common
most stars have planets in fact there
are more planets than there are stars
and there are many billions of stars so
there are many many many billions of
planets so what it means is there's
someplace to go and that is a big
discovery that's new we didn't know that
now hopefully some of those places are
interesting places to go we'll talk
about that a little bit but that is the
first big discovery now there's
something else that has developed that
I'll share with you a little while or
actually Freeman Dyson will share with
you a little
that also influences our thinking what
I'm gonna do tonight is report first of
all on the logic of this which I'll come
back to in a moment as well as a
conference that took place recently on
the starship century and the book which
Stuart held up that my friend and
colleague over here Jim Benford Jim wave
everybody knows who you are and you'll
see Jim on screen in a few minutes
Jim and his brother Greg put together
this book I've got a number of people to
write about it and when Jim and Greg
approached me with the idea of
participating in the book basically the
the question they asked was can we think
in some way rigorously about whether
this is a plausible possibility is this
something really worth thinking about
and so I actually was able to bring
together the two threads of my life one
of which is space and Astronautics and
one of my real personal passions which I
have not been able to exercise for a
very long time and scenario planning
that is the thinking about the future in
the long term in terms of multiple
scenarios so what I was able to do in
the course of participating in this
project with Jim and the other writers
who were involved in this was to
actually think through in a fairly
rigorous way the possibilities for
getting to the Stars and to see if the
question that I've asked up there is
galactic civilization inevitable is that
a meaningful question and what's the
answer to that question and and I'll
save that answer till the end so what
I've done here is first of all to lead
you through and my slides are fairly
simple the the logic of my thinking and
reasoning and analysis here but equally
important we had a very interesting
conference at UC San Diego in May that
Jim and Greg organized with a number of
this writers from the conference from
the book and science fiction writers
scientists and others and so I'm going
to take you to that conference in a few
video clips you'll see Jim on screen
with a few of the people and the
presentations and let them speak for
themselves the different scientists and
writers who are participants in that
conference and as you'll see some of
them are people you've seen here Neil
Stevenson
spoke Vernor Vinge ii spoke Freeman
Dyson whom you all I'm sure know spoke
and gave very important talk and he
revealed a new idea which I will save
for a little while because it also
changes the nature of the game as a
game-changing idea in a very big way so
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna lead
you through the thought process of these
scenarios as well as to share with you
some sense of what was happening at this
conference and in fact I'm going to
begin with
Jim Benford after I turn on my clicker
I'm gonna begin with Jim Benford and Jim
begins with telling us just why this is
such a hard problem
Jim the outer solar system has a lot of
promise a lot of interesting phenomena
that could cover belt the oil or our
cloud and you're going to hear about
that this morning and some speculative
ways from Freeman Dyson the distance out
to the to the stars themselves is
absolutely enormous
as you can see Alpha Centauri is three
hundred thousand a you out enormous
distance 4.3 light years and the other
targets in there are going to be the
nearer term things that we could
possibly send probes to and that's the
scale of what I just told you and you
can see we're way down here at unit one
Alpha Centauri is up there in
astronomical terms really and then we've
got the heliosphere and here where we
interface with the with the Galaxy
itself and the interstellar medium which
has not quite been reached maybe yes
maybe no by the void now we know in fact
it has been reached Jim made this
statement a few months ago and we've now
there so a Voyager has actually reached
it but the point is this is a really
hard problem it's really really really
far away any of you who were you know
fans of Hitchhiker's Guide you know this
is really big and the challenge and why
it's so interesting is this that our
solar system as beautiful as it is seen
by Voyager 2 and Voyager 1 is actually
fairly boring I mean the truth is that
you know Venus is too
and mercury is really too hot Mars is
too cold and arid and then we got a
bunch of gas giants and some moons and
stuff and we'll explore all of that but
it isn't very habitable and you know
you've all seen these amazing pictures
of Mars they're truly wonderful but you
know it's like living in an really arid
Siberia you know or Antarctica without
ice so it is not a place you really want
to spend much time and maybe someday
we'll terraform it and make it a bit
more habitable and we may explore some
of the moons of Jupiter and Saturn and
so on and if you haven't seen there's a
wonderful little new a science fiction
film called Europa report which is kind
of fun about reaching Europa a good
little science fiction film but
basically our neighborhood is pretty
boring and if we are really to explore
the universe we are going to have to get
to other stars we're going to have to
get the other star systems and the
distances are just simply almost
insurmountable and that's what the
challenge is but really is it
insurmountable well I'm not so sure
and in fact Jim found a remarkable
little forecast a prediction if you will
and I will let Jim tell you about the
prediction now predictions are hard to
do
and most people are not willing to do
them but Freeman Dyson did 45 years ago
in his prescient article in physics
today a renowned journal my favorite
magazine edited at that time by Gloria
Lumpkin who is with us here and the
articles written by Freeman Dyson who is
also with us here now will tell you
Freeman what you said
I predict that in about 200 years from
now barring it to destory the first
interstellar voyages will begin well
we're almost we're approaching we're
approaching a quarter of that time now
Dyson has doubled in age and perhaps
later today we might hear what he thinks
about the matter now and and we will in
a few minutes but I think it is actually
quite significant that someone like
Freeman Dyson one of the great
physicists of the last century man of
enormous intelligence and depth we've
all had the pleasure of hearing him
speak and reading his writing for many
many years actually believes it's quite
plausible that the ways of getting there
are quite imaginable and that the path
may not be quite as difficult as we
thought so having Freeman behind me
backing me helps a lot to be honest that
you you have someone like Freeman B
Dyson watching your back you're in
pretty good shape so what's really hard
here what's the hard problem well the
problem is twofold
the first is energy power how do you
power a vehicle to get to the Stars and
it is a really really long way it's
going to take an enormous amount of
energy to get there whatever means we
use it's going to take an enormous
amount of energy and I'll talk a little
bit about what that might mean
and the second big problem is as was
suggested by the voyage length of the
voyagers the voyages are going to be
long unless we have really amazing
faster than light travel for it in the
Star Trek world which we'll come back to
that in a little while unless we have
that these are going to be voyages of
decades centuries and maybe even
millennia and so the question is how do
we keep people alive for all of that
amount of time you know we know how to
keep people alive for weeks months maybe
even a year in space on the space
station
but getting to planets is already
difficult getting two stars is almost
insurmountable so those are the two big
challenges technically how do you power
a spaceship
and how you keep people alive so we're
gonna spend a bit of time talking about
the fundamental question of how and then
I want to go on to the question of why
because it actually does matter
why we want to go there and then put all
that together in a couple of several
scenarios for how we might get there and
what that might tell us so first of all
let's look at the question of can we and
that is how do we propel it and let me
say these slides are just kind of
considered an outline of the argument
well the first answer is no we can't and
that is if you ask most scientists and
engineers today they would say no
probably not going to happen
it's just technically too hard too big
too costly and therefore probably not
going to happen yes we can imagine maybe
getting around our solar system and I'll
talk a little bit about that in a moment
but moving across the vast interstellar
distances almost certainly not and you
know most scientists would say that but
a few are beginning to think about other
possibilities and so the second category
that I have there is slow and by slow I
mean less than the speed of light and
that is fairly slow few tens of
thousands of miles an hour think Voyager
may be a bit faster a few hundreds of
thousands of miles we now we haven't
gotten to that but maybe even if you
have something accelerating for a long
time maybe even a million miles an hour
might get us there but all that is still
relatively slow compared to the speed of
light which is 186,000 miles a second
okay
so our you know our solar system is
about some like 20 light hours across
okay so it's to go the whole solar
system you know from one side to the
other is maybe at the speed of light
roughly around 20 hours well we're
talking about four light years to the
nearest star so years versus hours
that's the kind of light what light does
for you so almost everything below the
speed of light is slow then there's the
outlandish possibility FTL stands for
faster than light will even come to that
possibility so the various scientists
who spoke at this con
it's actually laid out a number of
different possibilities for answering
these questions in some detail so let's
look at first of all why it is really so
hard now I said I worked at Apollo and
Jim Benford is going to tell us why
Apollo was wimpy this is a sobering
slide because you don't see things to
scale very much but that's dateless
unmanned now referred to as uncrewed the
V and going to compare to the Apollo of
which it was manned of course and it's
absolutely enormous the problems with
starships they don't scale well and
we're talking about scaling to very very
high speeds they're they're very large
they're very expensive they're very
inefficient in terms of payload the the
Apollo missions had about a 3% payload
fraction that is 97% of the of the
entire machine was gone by the time you
got something on target in fact you saw
precisely that phenomenon in the video
we saw earlier so all those pieces of a
titan 3c launch vehicle falling away
then the upper stage boosters falling
away then the Voyager boosters are
falling away and then finally you had
the actual Voyager that was left and the
problem is that these are chemical
rockets right so chemical rockets use
various forms of fuel hydrazine or
alcohol or kerosene or hydrogen and
oxygen
but basically it's a chemical reaction
of some sort and you are limited by the
chemistry of what's plausible there by
way of combustion so you have to carry
an enormous amount of fuel if you wanted
to fly for any distance so chemical
rockets are not going to get us to the
stars they probably are not even going
to get us to the planets but they
certainly are not going to get us to the
stars
so what lies beyond that well today we
have a source of power on earth which
generates an enormous amount of energy
from a relatively small volume of fuel
and that's nuclear power and so in fact
what we had was Jeff Landis from NASA
talking about the possibilities for
nuclear rockets but the nice thing about
nuclear thermal rocket
this is not an imaginary technology this
is not via graphs these are real
during the 1970s 60s and 70s when the
NASA plan was that we go to the moon and
then move on to Mars they said well
we're going to have to develop these
there were several programs one called
Nerva nuclear energy for rocket vehicle
applications one called rover a little
bit later there was a follow-on project
called Timberland which in fact was
mostly a paper study but they actually
built and tested these rocket engines
and here's several of these nuclear
rocket engines that were built and
tested during the 1970s so a nuclear
rocket could very well become the
workhorse of this whole this is how you
would fly around the solar system with a
nuclear rocket in fact when Stewart and
Zander and then Kevin and I all went
down to the to see Yucca Mountain
whether they were going to use that as
the waste dump with the sites for these
rocket tests we're still actually there
you could see the now decaying sites of
the nuclear test facilities for nuclear
powered Rockets the same place we were
testing nuclear weapons I might add so
these were actually built never flown in
space but it is plausible that we could
revive this this is within our technical
grasp so this is not something that is
the distant possibility if we choose to
do this this is something we could
actually do within the next 20-30 years
and this as a source of propulsion is
probably sufficient to get us to Mars
maybe to Jupiter Saturn the near
neighbourhood maybe even the entire
solar system you might begin to explore
with nuclear fission Rockets and you
know if you saw 2001 that was probably a
nuclear fission rocket in that long
discovery ship that they were flying on
their way out to Jupiter and it looked a
bit like the one here on screen
however nuclear fission is limited in
its power we have another nuclear
technology which we imagine which is
nuclear fusion were you getting more
power out of a smaller and smaller
volume the only problem with nuclear
fusion is that the only thing would
really know how to do with it is build a
bomb so far big bomb and nobody has yet
been able to harness nuclear fusion to
use it for any functional purpose eg for
power or anything else we have a project
over here in Lawrence Livermore labs the
National Ignition facility trying to use
laser beams to compress hydrogen and
produce fusion Europe has something
called the ITER the International
thermal thermonuclear energy research
facility and it is using magnetic fields
to try and compress hydrogen to produce
nuclear fusion and that may happen but
neither one of them has yet succeeded in
producing a sustained nuclear fusion
reaction now there's reason to think
that it may be plausible within the next
few decades but we ain't there yet and
this is already a hard physics problem
and an even harder engineering problem
but it is reasonable to imagine that
over the next fifty to a hundred years
that we would actually be able to
develop a fusion rocket so let's take a
look at one concept there was a
physicist named Buzzard who came up with
the idea of a ramjet using in fact
interstellar hydrogen there's a lot of
little bits of hydrogen out there and
hydrogen fuel being sucked in by
magnetic fields so Adam Crowell
described a Bussard ramjet so this
concept was well this one was visualized
originally by a rick's turn back for
cosmos but adrian man is ring visualized
it here pointing out all the basics so
you've got your magnetic field structure
possibly a giant torus hidden behind
this thing and then all these other sort
of hand waving sections thrown in plus
the fusion drive which any properly
operating fusion drives should probably
be glowing white-hot so
an improvement in an engineering sense
there was a bit more detail over this
concept once they figured out the right
fusion reaction all my fusion Rockets
are white out but the truth is of course
that we really don't know how to build
this yet but we can at least imagine and
understand a fair amount about the
physics of this and so the idea is that
this is a giant magnetic field at the
front just like an air scoop on a jet
engine is sucking in oxygen to feed the
the fuel onboard in the jet engine this
is sucking in hydrogen and feeding it
into a fusion reactor and pushing it out
the back end and producing an enormous
amount of thrust on a long-term basis
now you don't have to take most of your
fuel with you because it's out there in
the interstellar medium so it becomes a
plausible vehicle for that purpose so
that's the second concept for a slow
rocket and remember these guys may be
going really fast by our terms
but we're still in the slow space and
then the final concept is the idea of
sail ships giant ships now powered by
some kind of beams like say light beams
and again Jim Benford helps us
understand what a sail ship might be
like so Bob forward came up with this
kind of scheme for optics reasons you
use a this is in laser frequencies use
the laser and if the beam hits a
friend's which gives it good focal
properties and it accelerates the light
sailed in his model he was going to go
to Epsilon Eridani this idea basically
what you've got a laser beam somewhere
in near the earth maybe in or orbit near
Venus collecting huge amounts of
sunlight converting that to electricity
and producing a laser beam that points
out into deep space you have a giant
sail many many miles across capturing
that sunlight and powering the vehicle
forward just like a sail might be
powered by the wind and so this idea has
actually been tried on a very very small
scale in Earth orbit I mean tiny little
sails but in general the fizzy
this is well understood now it's a huge
engineering problem imagine building the
vast solar array vast lasers and so on
somewhere out in deep space and trying
to pilot a vehicle into interstellar
space now one of the fact that the the
things I didn't include in this talk was
Neal Stephenson's talk in which he
actually and I'll just mention it that
is that he spoke about a building a
tower 20 kilometers high as a way of
launching rockets and getting extra
impulse from the spin of the earth and
also figuring out how to do really big
engineering imagine a tower 20
kilometers high right in fact I think
you put it over here in the Central
Valley and you you you would be able to
see and of course it'd be higher than
anything in the Sierras you'd be able to
see it from downtown San Francisco
easily it's a great store and in the
book there's a short story about it at
the end of my talk I'll put up the URL
so you can see all the videos if you
want you go online and you can see
Neil's talk about building the
20-kilometer Tower so these are the slow
vehicles for getting to the Stars but of
course there's one more outlandish
possibility and that is the idea of
going faster than light but that means
reinventing physics because today
physics tells us that the speed of light
is the upper limit for any matter above
that it basically becomes energy e
equals MC squared
right we all understand that the energy
equals mass times the speed of light
squared so you take some mass and you
start moving it up in that light it's
gonna turn to energy and you are
essentially a light beam well that's not
a way to get to the Stars
you are a thermonuclear reaction
yourself so if we are going to do that
we really have to reinvent physics so
the question is is that plausible well I
live in North Berkeley home of many
Nobel laureates and we have pools on who
wins the next Nobel Prize and the most
recent winner in the neighborhood was
assault Perlmutter Saul lives a few
doors up the street on Poplar Street
where I live and Saul won the Nobel
Prize two years ago for discovering dark
energy he was led the team at Berkeley
that made the historic discovery one of
the great discoveries of the last
century that the universe is expanding
at an accelerating rate that something
is overcoming gravity and leading all
the objects in the universe to move
further away from each other at an
accelerating rate so there's some
mysterious force which they named dark
energy to go along with the other
mysterious mass called dark matter that
is overcoming gravity and producing an
effect which we don't really understand
the word dark means we don't know what
it is but literally we haven't the
slightest clue what dark energy is and
what dark matter is but we know it's
there we could see the effects so you
know start solves a friend and I went
for a walk with him not long ago and I
asked him the question you know look if
you think about the history of physics
and you know astronomy and so on there
was that moment about 500 years ago when
we still thought that the Sun went
around the earth and then along comes
Copernicus and Tycho and Galileo and
those guys and they figured out well you
know maybe the mathematics of orbits
would be a little bit easier if we put
the earth going around the Sun and lo
and behold it turned out to be a whole
lot easier and that's in fact the way
the universe works and we reinvent in
our universe about a hundred years ago
we did it again with Einstein and Bohr
with relativity and quantum theory and
again we got a real revision of our
model of physics so I asked Saul said
look you know you've discovered dark
energy there's dark matter there are
mysterious strings our friend martin
rees believes there's Martin there
multiple universes I mean the universe
has gotten kind of weird isn't this a
bit like the Sun going around the earth
might we not reinvent physics to make it
all work a bit more simply and he said
yes that's possible it is possible that
we might end up reinventing physics in a
quite fundamental way well there are two
possibilities the universe is weird and
that may be true or we're gonna reinvent
physics at some point along the way now
there's no guarantee that in that
reinvention we will find a way to go
faster than the speed of light but it
least becomes imaginable in fact so much
so that NASA actually has scientists
today working on an idea for using
wormholes so in fact let's look at what
that might look like from time summary
we assuming that stable wormholes exist
and that we can master the physics and
engineering
of microscopic we're moles we may be
able to use them to explore the Stars
and to colonize extrasolar planets the
time spanning properties of relativistic
wormholes can be used to reach distance
star star systems and very short times
on the order of days or weeks or months
and wormhole time link connects
connections to the present when the
wormhole is launched the future means
that you can't you can go there without
having to wait basically you're creating
an einstein-rosen bridge to the stars
now I should also point out that this
idea I presented in a 1990 column so
it's been around a while and as far as I
know nobody no science fiction writer
has taken it taking it up as a basis for
stories I'm actually I think there isn't
one Peter Hamilton but that's another
point but the point is that we are
beginning to imagine ways of even
modifying our existing models of physics
to create ways to create short distances
through vast distances of space the idea
of a wormhole connecting two points in
space and time and somehow being able to
go through there from one place to the
other and instead of taking centuries in
millennia days weeks hours to get from
here to somewhere vastly distant now
this is really at the outer realm of not
even plausible but barely imaginable
today but if you think about it
therefore we've got a whole bunch of
slow concepts nuclear fission nuclear
fusion sale and even the possibility of
reinventing physics to come up with new
ways of getting there
so it does seem at least there we have
some ways of thinking about the question
of energy and propulsion well then the
next question is how do we live long
enough how do we actually survive there
and so here there are four basic ideas
and the first is one that actually has
been a number of stories and in fact in
whole earth review Stewart once spent
several issues covering space colonies
which were basically asteroids that have
been hollowed out and people lived
inside the asteroid and they grew food
and there were new kinds of power
sources and so on
well you can imagine that kind of a
vehicle that goes from here to
distant stars but takes many generations
and the people who leave don't get there
they die and their children
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
many generations later are the ones who
actually reach the distant stars having
lived many generations on board of ships
that's one concept second concept are
sleep ships anybody who saw avatar will
remember what that was like you know
basically people go to sleep for X
number of years and then you get wakened
when you get there using some kind of
suspended animation and upon arrival you
have not aged except a little bit and as
a result essentially you're able to make
voyages of many many many years now that
again both of these are concepts which
we can imagine with today's science it's
not thoroughly implausible to get to
either of those the third possibility is
what you might call relativistic ships
and one of the consequences of
Einstein's theory of relativity is that
if you're moving fast enough relative to
another object you experience time
differently than that object you were
have recently left so if you imagine say
twins one on the earth and one on a
relativistic ship the guy on earth
experiences time as we all do but the
guy who may be going it's a half the
speed of light experienced this time
much slower than we do on the earth so
let us say in a voyage where it might
take a hundred years earth time they
might have only experienced ten years
onboard the ship so they leave come back
say twenty years later and hundred years
have passed on the earth but only twenty
years for them well the life-support
problem is now much smaller we can
imagine years of life support in space
as opposed to centuries and so on so if
you could get up to a reasonably high
speed and that's not implausible with
say nuclear fusion Rockets you could
actually get relativistic ships now what
would happen of course most of these
would actually take earth time probably
centuries so you'd come back to a very
different world and the people who
launched it would never see it but the
people who went out and came back would
come back to a different world so that's
the third possibility and then the
fourth possibility is what we call
download ships
now this is again driven by something
quite distinctive the idea and this is
you know Ray Kurzweil is written about
if Danny Hillis has written about it the
idea of downloading consciousness into
some kind of electronic medium so we
make a copy of ourselves into an
electronic media of our consciousness
and that is what is launched to the
Stars no life support needed is some
kind of electronic device and it flies
off to the stars and can last as long as
we like as long as the electronic medium
lasts it lasts the advantage of this of
course we saw in Avatar because what you
can do with an electronic medium then
download into some other form at the
other end and if you are on an
inhospitable planet for human beings why
it might be just fine for your
electronic device that gets there or a
organism designed for that planet so it
allows you to explore non earth-like
planets as well so that becomes another
possibility if we can invent that and
why would we do that well you know this
is really how you pursue immortality
this is the pursuit not necessarily of
spaceflight but very long life and so
this might come from very different kind
of pursuit so that's the the four
possibilities for how we might actually
live long enough build ships that take a
long time multiple generations sleep
ships relativistic ships with different
time frames and download ships so we've
answered the questions a little bit of
how to propel it how to live long enough
but maybe the problem isn't quite as
hard as we thought and Freeman Dyson
gave us a new point of view on what the
interstellar medium might be like
Freeman there's no reason to believe
that the space between the Oort cloud
and the Kuiper belt is empty let me just
check on the time so we have about 10 to
10 minutes to go but I'll probably run a
bit over that we know that a large
fraction of all stars are born with
planetary systems it's likely that large
numbers of planets are also born
unattached to stars and we know that the
normal process of formation
evolution of planetary systems results
in the ejection of planets and of comets
from the system as a result of these
processes the universe probably contains
more unattached planets than stars and
billions of times more unattached comets
the space between our solar system into
none and the nearest stars is probably
infested with unattached planets and far
more numerous unattached comets in
addition there may be other objects of
intermediate kinds which we have not yet
observed from snowballs to black dwarf
stars it's quite conceivable that some
of the intermediate objects might be
alive a population of methodological
monsters making their home in space the
Polynesians were navigating the Pacific
for a thousand years before the
Europeans crossed the Atlantic island
hopping came first intercontinental
voyages later it's likely that the
future of our traveling beyond the solar
system will follow the same pattern so I
think this is a very important idea what
Freeman is telling us is that unlike our
previous image of a vast empty ocean
between here and the nearest stars that
it is in fact populated by lots of
matter planets comets black stars brown
dwarfs and so on what that means is that
instead of one big leap like Columbus
had to do it might be smaller steps from
the solar system to the cometary clouds
to the outer clouds to some more objects
along the way and critically what it
means is you might be able to pick up
fuel along the way hydrogen and other
carbonaceous materials you might be able
to pick up food and maybe even water
along the way so it changes the nature
of the problem fundamentally it says
maybe we can get there stepwise just
like the Polynesians did crossing the
Pacific rather than
busted crossing the Atlantic and so this
is really a very big idea if Freeman is
right and he has a tendency to be right
and the logic of it is I think very
compelling that the nature of the
problem is therefore not nearly as
profound as we might have imagined that
we can get there stepwise rather than in
big leap so all of that fits in now
there's one big wild card in this story
something that could again change the
question of why we want to go to the
Stars and it is this eg
extraterrestrials right question is
there life in the universe elsewhere
well of course today we have detected no
life anywhere else in the universe not
in our solar system not anywhere else
the little hints here and there on Mars
maybe little hints out of Europa Titan
so on but any meaningful detection of
life no and certainly not the planets
that we've actually detected elsewhere
in the universe yet but I think the odds
are and I think a lot of scientists
would agree that at least in some group
of planets somewhere we will find some
indication of life and you know at a
minimum it'll be scum you know think
about you know a kind of lake with algae
and bacteria and like that growing
fairly simple life or Earth say a
billion years ago before most of life
developed that's what it might be like
there's a pretty good chance we'll find
galactic scum but you might even get a
bit better than that a real biosphere
you know plants animals of various sorts
that seems quite plausible but the Big
Kahuna of course is intelligent life
will we find any hint of intelligent
life and I think the odds of that are
very poor you think about again how big
the universe is
you know our galaxy has several billion
stars in it and there are billions of
galaxies and the universe is about 14
billion years old our earth is only 4
billion years so many civilizations
could have come and gone elsewhere in
space and time we'd never know it it
could be so far away we'd never see them
are so far back in
time we'd never knew every trace is gone
after a billion years or so so the odds
of that are very very very poor
unless it's common which we may discover
that in fact life has spread around the
universe and we find you know we're part
of a galactic community that we just
didn't know about now I say all of this
because of course this is a very
powerful motivator ie why go to the
stars so now I want to turn to that
question in a little bit more rigorous
fashion as I said I do scenario planning
and good scenarios are built around
rigorous analysis and good imagination
well we've been doing a fair amount of
imagination so far let's do a little bit
of rigorous analysis and to do that I
basically built scenarios using the
United Nations long term population
forecasts the UN a few years ago did
just a kind of numerical exercise to
look at what would happen if today's
fertility rates stay roughly the same
and you would get a scenario of that is
moving relatively flat along here fairly
stable population somewhere around 9
billion a couple billion more than we
have
if the fertility rate goes up just about
half a point in over 300 years what
happens we get a population of 36
billion or if it drops by about 1/2 a
point it drops to about two and a half
billion so we have a range of possible
population forecasts of two and a half
billion to 36 billion tenfold rain huge
so I asked myself questions for how
could that all happen what would allow
us to happen why you know it's not hard
to imagine that it stays the same ie the
fertility rate comes down roughly around
the world and we end up with a
relatively stable population that's what
most people think so a to happen second
possibility is what would lead us to
increase population rather dramatically
and the only possibility I could come up
with was religion if you think about who
wants to have lots of babies it's the
conservative religions Christianity
Islam Hinduism even the Jews but we're
too small count you know we don't matter
we could have a lot of babies and it
wouldn't add up for a lot but the
billion Muslims
a billion Hindus there's a billion
Christians they all decide to have a lot
of babies the women decide it's a good
thing to have lots of babies for the
faith they could change the population
forecast and that's how you could get to
a high population maybe not 36 billion
but 2030 billion a lot of people and
religion isn't what you need for the
discipline to live on an earth like that
imagine cities that all look like
Manhattan cities of a hundred million
each hundreds of such cities
high-density leave the rest of the land
for agriculture think Paulo Salieri's
arcologies as a model so that's what a
religious scenario might be like the
second scenario is really kind of
stability and in this scenario this is
the scenario I've decided to say the
environmentalists are right that in fact
if you have too many people were just
not going to be able to be sustainable
this is a world of the depleting
resources water air climate change a
real mess on the earth where survival
really becomes an issue and then the
final scenario is as we live longer we
have fewer children and wealth and long
life go together so you imagine a world
of great wealth that eventually most of
the world catches up with the
industrialized West and we all live in a
very high level but relatively few
people two and a half billion people
lots of richest people living in big
estates all over the world but not too
many of them about two and a half
billion of them so those are my three
kind of core scenarios and out of that
then I said well all right now let's put
all these pieces together how will we
get to the stars why we're going to the
Stars into several possible scenarios so
the first scenario is we can't okay call
it stuck in the mud right we're stuck in
the mud that we got here it's the our
solar system forever that's all we can't
solve the problem of keeping people
alive we can't solve the propulsion
problem and I can tell you most serious
scientists and engineers would say
that's the scenario you know live with
it it's the solar system period end of
story well you know I'm not sure that's
such a great scenario it kind of lowers
the horizons of humankind pretty
fundamentally but it is certainly you'd
have to say given today's science the
scenario that you would have to bet on
however suppose actually
we do find ET out there we do get some
signals out there well one of the things
we learned in the Age of Exploration
that one of the important motivators for
exploration was of course bringing the
Word of God to the heathens
so imagine a second possible scenario
gods galaxies and in this scenario it's
an interstellar race to save the souls
of the aliens right the Christians have
got their ship going
the Hindus got their ship going and the
Muslims got their ship going and they've
got a race to the stars now I will tell
you that the only people who have a plan
on the earth to actually deal with
aliens are of course the Vatican they
actually do have a plan they have a
white binder at the Vatican the at the
Vatican astronomer actually has a plan
for what to do when the aliens arrive
because of course if you're the Vatican
you've got to have an answer right you
know what happens when the spaceship
lands you know in st. Peter's Square and
you know the Pope is greeted with an
alien you know has he been saved right
or not did Jesus show up there or not
that all I'll show up there or not so
it's actually a meaningful theological
question but it's a very powerful
motivator and one can imagine also if
this is a religious driven scenario this
is the scenario of generation ships
think monastery right discipline for
generations so you think about a ship
designed to carry the monks to carry the
mullahs to carry the priests all into
deep space to bring the Word of God to
the aliens so that is if we find
something out there worth converting so
that is the first of our real
interstellar scenarios gods galaxies
let's take a look at the second scenario
escape from a dying planet well as I
said suppose the environmentalists are
right that 9 billion exceeds the
carrying capacity of the planet and
we're really in serious trouble well the
different civilizations of the earth say
the Anglo files the Chinese the Indians
the Arabs all decide they're going to
save their civilizations and begin to
launch slow ships sleep ships because
now we want to carry a lot of people on
board you know thousands of people all
in sleep lots of embryo
those unborn to be born on the new
planet in the distant space basically to
start over and a lot of people think
this is absolutely essential because
otherwise our species is genuinely at
risk particularly maybe get hit by an
asteroid or something like that along
the way so the second scenario is save
the species via sleep ships and you get
in fact long slow voyages to distant
stars even if those stars appear
uninhabited planets appear uninhabitable
or at least there's some kind of
biosphere that might be livable so
that's the the third of our scenarios
first is we can't second as gods galaxy
and third is escape from a dying planet
but of course today the space effort is
being driven by some really interesting
people you know NASA is in a bit of
trouble it's got budget problems but of
course the really interesting story are
people like Richard Branson Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos all with private space
programs right so the third final
scenario is trillionaires in space it's
going to take trillions and so you think
the great-grandson of Richard Branson or
thinkers have got long life maybe
Richard himself or Ilan's great
grandchildren or bezos's great
grandchildren now going to the stars and
of course you allow a couple hundred
years at a compound interest rate
billions become trillions so they're
able to fund it and of course
billionaires like to go fast
trillionaires so they're the ones who
build first of all the relativistic ship
right so their ships go faster they're
the ones who actually can have slow life
in space while fast life happens here on
earth or secondly the download' ship
right billionaires and trillionaires
want to live forever right so they're
the ones who solve the download' problem
and copy themselves into some kind of
electronic device and send themselves
off to the stars and finally they're the
ones willing to take the big risks to
fund really outrageous research things
that might actually lead to fundamental
new physics and go faster than the light
so one can imagine the scenario of
trillionaires in space in races you can
just see Elon and Richard and Geoff
heading out for their separate stars and
see who gets there first right and gets
there fastest and so on and you know as
ridiculous as that sound if I'd said to
you 10 years ago that the space program
would be driven by Richard Branson
somebody you'd never heard of called
Elon Musk and the guy who's doing Amazon
that is now the space program well that
is in fact today the reality so this is
a scenario which has already begin to
play out on earth today it's not
implausible over the next couple hundred
years so those are the four scenarios
we're stuck on earth we're stuck in our
solar system we're bringing the Word of
God to the universe or we'll try to
escape our dying planet or we are racing
to the stars with the trillionaires now
I put these together these several
scenarios but these all can be combined
in different ways there are many
scenarios here different motivations
different forms of propulsion different
levels of population these are just
three or four versions of many scenarios
the point is that there are many
different ways of doing this there isn't
a single way there's no one single right
answer
so in conclusion basically and this is
the conclusion that essentially Jim
asked me to think about and came to that
there are many many pathways to the
Stars that most of them actually get us
there this few that don't but most of
them actually eventually get us their
name may not be a hundred years or 200
years but we will get there given these
so the bottom line is yes a galactic
civilization is almost inevitable the
fate of humankind is to in fact play out
our lives play out our civilization on
the galactic stage not the solar stage
so one day your children or my son Ben
here will have the opportunity to travel
to the Stars to see the universe and to
bring humankind into the greater
galaxies thank you very much
if you want to see the full videos
that's the URL for the conference all
the videos are on the on that site
all right here meanwhile back down and
here on earth it's appalling lease local
gym ban forgets the first question how
come long now contribute to interstellar
thinking well I think this is one way we
can do it is to spread the idea but I
think I expect we're gonna be around for
a long time long out decades maybe
centuries so I think we can come back
and revisit this problem everyone said
oh I'll report to you and say 50 years
100 years 200 years so you know come
back for the next lecture say in 50
years time I'll be 117 so you know I may
be moving a bit slower on stage by then
but I'll come back and report to you
then and see how we're doing there's
always the fatal flaw mode and as soon
as Freeman Dyson said well there's lots
of stuff out there and we can do island
hopping and and don't worry there's
comets and planets hither and yon you
know the first happy thought is great
we'll just go from island to island and
then the second unhappy thought is
you're going rather fast and probably
not able to veer and isn't there just
lots of stuff that will absolutely
collide with and that's the end of the
trip well yeah the truth is that is a
well-recognized risk and even if you
didn't have big rocks out there to run
into dust just simply the interstellar
medium of a lot of dust you know imagine
trying to fly through a sandstorm you
know instead of being as dense as a
sandstorm you're moving fast that it's
apparent density is much greater so it's
a real issue you er needs to devise
technologies for actually handling that
so for example one of the thoughts was
the front end of your spaceship should
be a giant ice ball with your water for
example and that is your deflection
device and that's what you know the dust
and any rocks that you made encounter
bounce off of you have something that
sort of sacrificial in front
exact bumper the jacquimo it's a real
issue and you know if you're moving near
the speed of light of course your radar
beam out in front of you you know you're
gonna be right behind it exactly it's
you know it is a it's a real challenge
and shouldn't be dismissed or really
seriously hungry ramjet that likes all
that stuff yes so that's the other part
yeah but there your earring me for
hydrogen not big rocks Jon bet Houser
asked what are the best steps within our
solar system to prepare for interstellar
voyage well I think there are two big
things one is continue to develop the
rockets that the propulsion not chemical
rockets nuclear and then ultimately
fusion rockets for actually exploring
our solar system and make sure that you
have to have the capacity to take human
beings and we can do amazing things with
the robot so we're gonna hear about the
Mars Lander I think in the next lecture
right it's just you know truly one of
the most virtuous technical achievements
anybody's ever done in astronautical
engineering but having said that
building spaceships that can carry
people around the universe around our
solar system is number one and number
two is life support you know can you
actually create life support that let
keeps you alive for years not months for
deeper space voyages Jupiter Saturn and
so on those are voyages that are years
long and if we solve the years problem
then the decades probably become
somewhat easier so I think those are the
two big things can we build rockets of
you know spaceships that actually get us
around the solar system and can we
people keep people alive well the best
planetary explorations happened so far
as without people on board right you
know including the recent Mars landing
curiosity these are robots and the trend
seems to be that space exploration is
not done by meat sacks like us it's done
by you know downloadable or
transmissible intelligence and digitally
guided increasingly AI smart robots and
as soon as Vernor Vinge a singularity
happens presumably the robots will look
at us across that membrane and say we're
going you're not hey that's a plausible
scenario
I mean I it is it is virtually certain
that the first things that go to the
star I mean we already have a Voyager
you know is already on its way and the
intentional missions of sending
something say to Alpha Centauri or out
to one of the rocky planets of that
we've discovered further out that will
almost certainly be unmanned that we
will want to lose those probes in any
event part to test that hypothesis of
the nature of the interstellar medium so
that will almost certainly happen first
I think robots are really great I think
we can do a lot with that and you know
I'm enormously impressed with what we've
learned I mean the Cassini mission
around Saturn is just spectacular
but there's something deeper going on
here and and and I think that's what
this is really about is about humanity's
aspirations our dreams our visions our
sense of purpose something larger than
we are and by this I don't mean anything
spiritual that's true for many other
people I mean just that sense of
constant moving forward as a human
species and I think that's what will
drive us toward the Stars that that
motivation is really really deep in our
genes that we somehow want to go out
that's what's driven us around the world
it's one of the motivations it's driven
around the world not only what you know
drove us in part to this to go to the
moon one hopes that we have the
equivalent of a good motivation like the
Cold War that managed to get us to the
moon without the Cold War probably no
moon flight right
in fact with no warm probably no Rockets
either so you know we wouldn't have the
v2 without World War two
no Verner von Braun no Saturn so on so
you know III think we need to find other
motivations than war to develop these
things but human motivations seem to
drive our need to go outwards okay it's
a skilled scenario issed
you've given us always giddy
multiplicity of ways to get out there
play out this stuck in the mud scenario
a little bit well look it's stuck in the
mud on in our solar system still it's a
fairly rich body of planets there's a
lot of stuff one can do by way of
exploration but basically we are not the
only real alternative other than X
and maybe the space colonies that you
wrote about Stewart you know 30 some 40
some years ago ie hollowed-out asteroids
and people living near Earth orbit out
Lagrangian points near the moon spent in
Cannes with that sort of thing I think
that's plausible but I find it unless we
do some serious terraforming of Mars and
that's a millennial problem that
significant meaningful presence off the
earth is very unlikely another practical
question he may ask when you get quote
there or what mechanism be used to
decelerate are you just to go zinging
past it and there the speed of light but
that's a really I was a really good
planet just too late well all aside from
the sale the basic rocket for the race
you know the nuclear rock at the fission
rocket fusion rocket you can basically
reverse the rock you know put it in the
other direction and use your rocket to
slow you down if we let that clip with
Jim talking about sales run a bit longer
forward came up with ways of modifying
the trajectory of the vehicle and
actually maneuvering in deep space still
using testing sales maneuvering with
wind so that becomes possible though
there's a great science fiction story in
fact tau0 there's something called the
Tao foundation Tao is square root of 1
minus V squared over C squared and tau
equals 0 at the speed of light and it's
about a spaceship that is of one of
these Bussard ramjet and they can't stop
it right it just goes faster and faster
and faster and faster zipping through
solar system zipping through galaxies
and relativistic speeds and people can
feel it oh there's a speed bump another
galaxy we just went through right
because they experienced millions of
years in seconds now because they're at
point nine nine nine nine nine nine see
and it you know it really dealt with the
problem what happens if you can't stop
well it does call attention to this how
narrow-minded this project is so far
you're not talking about intergalactic
travel at all oh you're right we're not
yet we have not yet begun to think about
how we visit Andromeda for example or
even the Magellanic Clouds which are in
our neighborhood so many galaxies in the
orbit
and in fact something I would recommend
if people amazing spirits one of the
other speakers there which I didn't show
what was it even the gardener John
lumber so John Lomborg is a painter an
artist who painted the space scenes for
cosmos and for this Smithsonian in Kona
he has built a garden that's open to a
couple of publics called the Galactic
garden it's about 150 fact the size of
this hall and it is think about a garden
maze right but now it's the arms of the
galaxy right and he there has a little
group of leaves about this big on each
of which is a couple little dots of
diamonds and gold each of those as a
star it's our whole little neighborhood
and then you see this one little cast
little a wall of plants and that's just
a local little bit of an arm of the
galaxy and then you realize just how big
it is
I mean I was an amateur astronomer as a
kid and I had no idea how big the galaxy
was until I walked around long Borg's
galactic garden to get the Kona it's
worth going to see the galactic garden
it will all you so you spent time
chatting with Perlmutter about there's
there more possibilities in physics and
since he stirred up one of them he's
presumably optimistic that there's a lot
more weirdness what's and you must have
talked about this what does he think
about interstellar travel and
reinventing physics oh he thinks it's
unlikely you know I mean and I mean
Sol's a genius but as Einstein described
himself as the last classical physicist
he grew up in the world of Newtonian
physics and reinvented it
but he never could intuitively grasp the
world that he invented himself he never
was comfortable quantum theory for
example said you know that was the
famous life Scott life aligned God does
not play dice with the universe and so
he was very uncomfortable with the
universe that was the result of the
physics he helped create
I think the physicists who are creating
this new you
verse have a hard time being comfortable
with the new universe that they might be
leading to there's another practical
question from James Walter who's
basically saying cosmic radiation out
there is fierce and constant and so far
waves of mass can unless your robot is
involves a whole lot of mass how is that
is anyone dealing with that issue yeah
the the the point that's being made in
the question is the one of the
discoveries we've made in recent years
is that we actually do have a problem of
even interplanetary flight little an
interstellar flight that solar radiation
is pretty intense and particularly if
you have a solar storm and you get you
know big bursts of radiation you would
need on board shelters and in fact the
space station has a plan if you get hit
by a solar storm there are areas that
are denser than others to protect
yourself the general idea that people
talk about is some kind of mass and this
goes back to the water idea you know you
basically put the living capsule inside
a big volume of frozen water and you use
that water to protect yourself against
radiation till you get to where you want
to go Steve from livestream sorry it
describes themselves its what changes
and our assumptions about resource
allocation and economics will be needed
before any one can seriously undertake a
project like this well I think we don't
actually have to make big changes I mean
first of all let's just take a look at
the three different scenarios
well the religious scenario well who's
the wealthiest people on the planet it's
the Vatican right I mean they have no
trouble with resources I mean they
managed to assemble you want to see
wealth go see the Saudis if you want to
see religious support there and so on so
you know religious wealth if it chooses
to be directed in this way plenty of it
to go around
desperation okay well that's the second
scenario and that's a harder economic
challenge but it is the competitive
challenge of difference of civilizations
and marshaling the resources of survival
I bet this question if we're scrabbling
for resources pooling vast resources to
you jump out of it actually is one of
the things that gets precluded and when
you're scrambling probably unless you
get so desperate that it really is a
lifeboat kind of mentality right and
some entity puts up a large wall and
with its resources keeping everybody
else out and the third one is really
rich people and compound interest well
that was you know the long now
foundation is partly based on Robert
Heinlein's long range foundation in the
book time for the stars in which they
were basically the accumulated so much
capital that they would have to they
have fear stupid ways to just get rid of
it spend it on things like space travel
well I mean look we said it pays off
usually and they become the most rich
entity around they can do anything well
we are seeing it out San Francisco Bay
almost every day and maybe for one more
day
what billionaires will do with their
money right feel really outrageous
sailboats
here's Christian little biology question
Karthik asks what do you think of
possibilities of finding life-forms
based on something other than carbon
very good question I mean we are
basically carbon life-forms there are
various other combinations of chemical
compounds that might yield things that a
a phenomena that would be life living
systems so there's been talk about
systems built on silicon systems built
on phosphorus various combinations of
chemicals that like carbon can combine
in various ways to yield
self-replicating systems and that's the
issue can they replicate carbon is easy
to replicate it is quite common in our
particular neck of the woods but one can
imagine that there are other chemical
compounds that could be put together to
create life and we've got little hints
of that in some of the extremophiles
here on earth as well so I think it's
not implausible that we might find non
carbon-based life elsewhere also I could
imagine they're starting to be
prospective
a different form of genetic code that we
and other life forms might operate on
where you throw in an extra chromosome
which is not you know the kludgy
spaghetti code that zillion years of
random evolution has given us it's smart
engineers putting things you know where
they belong and making a really
efficient and better and the wheel is
better than the leg there's things like
that you could do that genetically so
you can imagine some life-forms being
developed which might be a continuity of
us or squirrels in those that are very
smart squirrels that you crank up that
dial all right they get to be the
instead of robots they're basically
genetically spaced adapted creatures
that are way better than us at living in
any place other than this kind of narrow
little biological envelope or good
actually I think that's a very plausible
scenario genetic modification of human
beings or other organisms to actually
make them better suited both in life or
size I'm you know one can imagine a
little tiny space of course or very long
lived space explorers than are
genetically modified this morning
science times I had an article on on how
complex chromosome genes actually are
that it turns out to be much more
complicated than we even thought you
know so that we have a lot of learning
to do but one can imagine that out of
that comes the ability to do that real
fast probably a question that many
20-somethings which he describes himself
as oh he in fact he's a twenty-something
with a BA in philosophy what would you
suggest that Ralph do to dedicate his
life to this problem learn science
for starters that that's not a bad thing
take a vow of poverty too and find
yourself a religious order committed to
the Stars I think the path is pretty
well clear even it first start one you
know what I can't imagine a religion not
necessarily one of the existing ones but
wanted to take shape that is sort of
shaped around we are you know to hell
with the afterlife in heaven we're gonna
just make it yeah go there and and and
make it happen and come join cuz we're
all so happy now that this looks like a
wonderful thing to dedicate our lives
many generations to when you were
talking about the religious version of
God's galaxy I was thinking you know
you're right monasteries they've they've
done that sort of thing that really
dedicated tight communities
intellectually based some extent they're
once you do multi-generational
cathedrals exactly and they would just
say this is our Cathedral and it is you
know going to take generations and we
like that I mean it long now we approve
that but long now has a very strong
guideline that we don't do religion so
yes because religions get in trouble and
then you're already in trouble
proof art poppin raises a question I
think craig Venter did which is why
don't we send precursor life-forms say
in a bacterial or something other solar
system the other planets initially so to
get an idea how this works then deceived
them we'll probably do that by accident
anyway that is it is not implausible
that we've already done it to Mars with
our Mars Landers in fact there's a lot
of discussion in recently you know maybe
we've exaggerated the need for that kind
of purity and cleanliness but having
said that I think it's a very good point
I think it's highly likely actually that
if we discover say rocky planets would
say water say that but with no life with
are we finding that water is kind of
common
common than we might have thought let's
suppose let's and stuff like that yeah
exactly
so say we discovered around a star 50
light-years that it's a watery world
okay well we can find no signs of any
life well we might in fact send some
biological samples in advance to start
populating that planet with a biosphere
say for example the atmosphere might not
be adequate for us well in fact we know
that the symbiosis of oxygen and co2 in
plant life and so on is how we produce
in an atmosphere we can breathe you can
imagine terraforming a water planet to
make it habitable just that way there's
a question from can't read the name
looks like Anke Angie Oh modest question
is her solar system a valid spacecraft
our solar SYNC about it the answer is
yes it's a spacecraft moving around the
galaxy the galaxy you know these and we
live in a pinwheel galaxy the Milky Way
is a giant pinwheel with about three or
four big arms that are rotating the
whole arms are moving each Sun is moving
around the center of that or galaxy in a
big warm it that takes about a couple
million years to go around a couple
hundred thousand years quarter million
years thank you helping get it right
quarter million years to make a single
orbit so it is a big spaceship our earth
is a spaceship going around the Sun at
about 65,000 miles an hour in its orbit
so you know
Buckminster Fuller was right then you
know any rote operating manual for
spaceship earth we are a great big
spaceship in an even bigger spaceship
our Sun our solar system moving around
our galaxy but of course our whole
galaxy is moving away from the Big Bang
into space that is expanding is that
gonna defeat efforts to steer the solar
system to interesting places I think
we're a ways yet from steering the solar
system I think but you know
it's conceivable but I think that's a
bigger problem that would prepare to
even think seriously about at the moment
how do you steal a solar system
he's thinking about it I'm thinking
about other steer this conversation
further because it is a conversation
that civilization is having with itself
as we get these capabilities we get the
genetic capabilities and get to have to
rethink a whole bunch of things you get
these space travel capabilities we see
the photographs from the amazing Saturn
work we think about Europa and you know
getting there and this movie dimension
and the the the you know we're doing the
extinction and people keep saying and
are hearing oh gosh that was you know
science fiction only last week it's
called Jurassic Park yeah and so the
science fiction to reality gradient
keeps happening and we get sort of
pissed off that some things don't happen
you know the jetpacks or whatever it may
be but and there was a period for about
ten years there were science fiction
writers and years I could tell got sort
of freaked out by the idea of the
singularity and that there was this
event horizon that you couldn't beyond
and Charlie's cross and a few other just
went zooming through it but everybody
else just says screw it right about the
present it's pretty futuristic anyway
but now there's this Neil Stevenson is
you know pushing hieroglyph which is the
idea of since the current generation of
space explorers and really adventurous
scientists were inspired as you were by
certain science fiction that happened
when they were 10 years old they're
trying to make the kind of science
fiction happen for 10 year olds now
there's probably a great many more of
them not only female as well as male but
a whole lot of people in the world that
are seeing avatar and these movies and
are exposed to science fiction thinking
they were not in the previous generation
so presumably there's a shockwave wave
front of new science fiction inspired
folks all over the world who have the
ability now to connect with each other
and there's kind of a dyson sphere of
visionaries who are in the mode of we'll
wait why why not you know do this thing
I've read about this seems kind of cool
you see that happening absolutely look I
mean so many things we take for granted
would have seemed absolutely I landed
sending pictures through walls right you
know if I said to you in 1880
before too long we're gonna be able to
send pictures through walls yeah but how
do you do that through molecules of a
solid wall well you know we do that
every second every day all over the
planet right nobody thinks twice about
television broadcasts any longer there
are so many things of that character
that had seemed completely implausible
but today are just quite routine some
things are proven too hard energy is
proven to be very difficult hence no jet
packs no flying cars but many other
things I mean Irene firm ation devices
are vastly more powerful that we only
imagined a few years ago then we would
all be carrying the equivalent of
smartphones at our pocket or camera
every phone would have a camera in it or
now you know the Google glass begins to
look like things that david brin science
fiction writer was only writing about
only a few years ago so I think the
interest in science fiction is still
universal I think you see it all over
the world sciences the recent science
fiction movies everybody can identify
with all over the planet and I think
these do create a vernacular you look
you and I were involved in writing a
science fiction film called Minority
Report and so many things we wrote that
we put on screen in that film have now
come to pass so I think it is a powerful
tool I think it is something that
inspires imagination I think it actually
does make a difference and I think
imagination is essential if we're
actually going to have that kind of
future that we want to have in the
absence of that imagination
life becomes very pedestrian thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you